just go out that door videos please turn
your phone's off a button on silent if
that's okay
thank you for members and offices coming
today the first thing is the apologies
have got counselor open I haven't got
anybody else so nobody knows about it if
or Julie counts of juice Barry nope okay
good good good enough just two minutes
of the meeting here on the 2nd and the
15th of March and have we any
permissions on those are can I sign them
off yeah okay thank you any declarations
of interest there are none number four
amendments to the hackney carriage and
I'm assuming you've all read the notes
leaflets etc if you want Jan to go
through them what do you want to ask
quickly the phenotypes it's 2012 so
Venus whatever number of changes
legislation right we went through the
conditions and had a look on public
safety and other bits and pieces that we
would you know sort of really pulling
all it for public safety really so we're
looking at putting the side loads in in
for the wheelchair accessible vehicles
and I can doubt your reasons for that as
well and evidence for that we're looking
at putting penalty points in and for
minor issues and we're looking at doing
a safety and vehicle safety audits
just to make sure that they are could
find everything they need in the school
bus series of objects rustling vehicles
I'm strapped in and first aid kits and
things and that they're needing them so
if you've got any questions go into it
any debt or detect issues um did we not
have safety issues on me is this
something new that's happening now or
well we had and we have an inspection
shape but it's a sign before saloon car
as it is for everything else this will
be just for wheelchair accessible this
at this and vehicle or do it and it will
include the straps that they strap the
wheelchair in it won't include and the
all the signage there has to be certain
signage on there
and they have to have different kind of
handles for somebody with sight problems
because they handle it they need to get
out it's all of those issues and they're
not on our regular inspections shoe so
it's just bringing in a more enhanced if
you like inspection sheet for the
wheelchair accessible vehicles okay has
this already gone out to the license in
with guys who own these cabs except I
mean have you had any have you had any
questions or problems and regarding this
you know little because they're
conditions of a license it's not policy
we don't have to go out to consultation
right so these are the conditions of
their license I'm not sure I mean it was
in the report so I've noted it but there
was this concern that with this with
these new bit of legislation that we
were being there could be a reduction in
the number of wheelchair friendly
my caps and there was concern that this
the number of caps that were available
would reduce and only have saloons is
there any mitigation in that or if
you're licensed to have a wheelchair and
you can't go back down to a saloon only
or is or is that likely to have a
knock-on effect on or is it not is he
likely to go the other way I don't know
all the new hackney carriage should be a
course from October will have to be more
accessible sideloading right so if they
want to be a hackney carriage driver
they need to put one of those vehicles
on so if that will increase what we've
already got now any ones that are coming
up to an age where they you know they're
two years we know they know their
grandfather right so we'd have a mixture
but still like the mixture because some
disabled people can't get in the higher
vehicles if you know got problems with
their legs and bits and pieces so we
still keep a good mixture of Vietnam
vehicles so the saloon cars would space
saloons but any new ones would be
accessible vehicles and the wheelchair
accessible vehicles that are on at the
moment the reloading ones we've got when
they become of an age they have to
change them to side loading so there's
that mean ultimately all taxis will the
saloon taxi will disappear no because if
you've got your play you can keep that
played for 50 years and you can see the
saloon on every time it's just if you've
got a wheelchair accessible and that's
very alowed in we want to change that
aside for penalty points baby this is so
is this a new scheme this is indication
of a penalty point scheme is this good
new and the other question is and just
my only point was that with me is when
you say penalty points minor minor
problems what do you mean by mine
see I was always got somebody coming
forward who is breaching the laws of
attraction and they just come anyway and
you decide whether or not they are fit
and proper person so how is this a
little painted for its scheme gonna go
to work it's the little things like
constantly I'm in a dirty car your
customers don't want to get into a dirty
car finally to notify self a change of
address expose little things that are
not serious enough to bring them in
front of the year but if we've got
somebody that repeatedly does all these
little bits and pieces we can give them
penalty points when they get to a
certain amount then we can bring them to
you and say okay they've now reached a
limit limit penalty points they've done
this this business in it's easier for
you to make that judgment before
bringing somebody to you to say they've
got a dirty vehicle we'd be in here
every five minutes so it's just
addressing those minor issues really and
that if we have got somebody that's not
looking at these minor issues and
they're building up and building up we
can bring them in them in front of you
and you can make the decision okay and
actually on page six
unless it's there and the penalty points
were proposed in as well this is other
other authorities do do any two points
schemes for that reason but it's just
something we'd like to introduce any
other questions or two when this I have
with a recommendation on page four point
four first one is number one the
amendments of the councilors license
conditions in relation to hackney
carriage private hire vehicles drivers
and operators etc are you happy with
that and give me two resolves that one
number one and it's number two on 84.5
that the new per viewpoint scheme is set
and the officers report are we happy
with that and we can great with that one
as well
great yeah I find that I may point to
that recognition that this committee is
recommending to council yeah that's fine
[Music]
[Laughter]